[Music]
do
[Music]
the movement of this antithesis is in
the first instance the formal production
of an identity of what the evil
consciousness
is in its own self and what it declares
itself to be
it must be made apparent that it is evil
and thus its existence made to
correspond to its essence
the hypocrisy must be unmasked
this return of the disparity present in
his hypocrisy
into a correspondence is not already an
accomplished fact because hypocrisy
as is commonly said demonstrates its
respect for duty
and virtue just by making a show of them
and using them as a mask to hide itself
from its own consciousness
no less than from others
as if in this acknowledgement of the
antithesis
within itself identity and
correspondence were
implied only it is
at the same time just as much reflected
out of this spoken acknowledgement and
into itself and the fact that it uses
what is an essence as a being for
another
implies rather its own contempt for that
essence
and the exposure to everyone of its own
lack of any substantial being
for what lets itself be used as an
external instrument shows itself to be a
thing which possesses no
importance of its own
in paragraph 661
we see the side of the universal the
side of
others the consciousness that is not
that of conscience but rather that
motivated by duty
attempting to impose or you might even
say
squeeze the hypocritical consciousness
into an admission of its hypocrisy
and therefore a endorsement and embrace
of its evil you know perhaps so that it
will
realize how it's gotten things wrong and
then you know knuckle under and conform
to the universal to this this
realm of you know mutual acknowledgement
in language
in the community and instead what we get
is an escape or perhaps even a
resistance
on the part of the consciousness that
has now been labeled
as evil that is maintaining this
distinction
within itself that is acting and acting
according to
its own rule or impetus
or its own view on the situation what we
call
its conscience it's gavison it's
certainty of itself gevis heights right
so how does this actually play out well
we could frame it in terms of we want to
be
facetious again the universal strikes
back but it's
its blow is actually not as
effective as it seems so he begins by
saying
the movement of this antithesis this
opposition
right gag and zots is in the first
instance the
formal production of an identity of what
the evil consciousness
is in its own self and what it declares
itself to be it must be made apparent
that it is evil and so made apparent
by whom for whom well this is
a assertion or the reflection of a
desire
on the part of you know ostensibly
the universal the algamina right
which which is the the community itself
and the members of the community the
consciousnesses that are motivated by
what they take to be duty rather than
acknowledging
the the you know extrinsic
or eccentric uh decision
of consciousness on the part of what is
being labeled now
is the evil consciousness and it
actually could be an evil consciousness
it could be evil in a number of
different respects or it could just be
being labeled as evil
i was you know thinking as i was reading
through this again
about that scene in the sound of music
where you have that song right
how do you solve a problem like maria
maria later to become maria von tropp
right
i forget what her original name is
is a nun in or actually maybe not even a
nun a postulate rather
in an order of nuns and she's rather
free spirited and it's not as if she's
completely
random she does things with a purpose
aids vac right for example when she
winds up in the household and the
children need new clothes she takes the
curtains
and turns them into outfits right and so
that's sort of a going against the order
but
there's always a justification why is
she out there
spinning around at the beginning and you
know the
grassy plains and the alps well she's
celebrating nature or something like
that right there's something
motivating that conscience that
consciousness
and so you know there's this attempt to
impose this
this identity identity is like height
here
so this is right referring back to the
unga like height
what's being translated as disparity
here we could say equality and
inequality
or even commensurability and in
commensurability as well
although it's not exactly the same
that's why i chose to represent this
with a sort of
equal sign with a question mark
superimposed over it
there's a conflict there and merely
asserting something to be an identity
merely asserting something
to have been equalized is not the same
thing
as it truly being so so what is being
equalized here let's look at that first
so he says that um the return
the the formal production of an identity
of what the evil consciousness is in its
own self
and what it declares itself to be so a
little bit later he's going to talk
about
essence and existence and
miller by the way is going to equate or
rather in his translation choice a
little bit later in the paragraph
is going to use the word essence in
place of the on zeke and that's
perfectly fine right because it is
what it is in itself the essence of
of the thing so the
and we'll get to the das booze in just a
moment the
let's just go along the evil
consciousness here
all right what it is in its own self we
saw that there's this disjunction
between
the the universal what the in itself
and what it expresses uh
auschwitz this is interesting here
that it's it's you know auschwitz
because
this is a general term auschwitz you
know expressing
but it also has that linguistic element
to it which is going to show up
a little bit later here in the paragraph
in spracha right
schracha rada communication discourse
language is the medium in which the
universal is manifesting itself
at this point what allows there to be a
community of recognition
so what it is expressing is taking place
both in the medium of action and also
you know in the the the ex the medium
of some sort of expression it could be
in words it could be in
attitudes right because we're talking
about hypocrisy
we've got this rich language here of
taking
the mask off actions themselves are
expressive
so what what this is expressing is its
dozen its existence
and here we have you know an interesting
invocation on hegel's part
of something that he doesn't often you
know engage in here in the phenomenology
this age-old discussion of the
difference between
essence and existence
right and being the being of a person
encompassing both of these this goes far
far back into medieval philosophy where
it plays a major role and even ancient
philosophy
as well the difference between existence
and and essence you know
also we might say between accident and
substance
now in this case however what's being
expressed is
really the we might call it the
the other essence i'm showing what my
essence is
i'm determining what i am in my
existence again i've pointed this out
before
people often take the existentialists as
you know going against a hegel of
essentialism
and this is a prime example where
there's a good bit of existentialism
already there in hegel
at least in some of the shapes of
consciousness so we've got these
these two sides to things are they
actually
being equated and we should think about
what it means to be equated if
if this is indeed sort of an evil
hypocritical
existence then we could say well the the
you know the glycogen the equation the
uh leveling things out should make this
no longer bad but good right the
universal should take priority over it
but we might also say no no this is
showing itself as
essentially evil and we want them to
express that rather than saying that
they're doing something different we
want them to label themselves the way
that we're labeling them
i mentioned i would come back to this
idea of das bouzon
so what is what is business it's evil
right and this dos here
is being translated you could say
referentially back to the consciousness
right so uh here we go
what the evil consciousness is in its
own self
hegel doesn't actually say uh that's
buzzer
busan or anything like that or or
conscience would be closer because
gevisen can be dos can be neutral right
it's okay to read that in but i think
it's also a little bit more
rich if we think about this this is also
defining what is evil
what is das biza what is the evil what
is
evilness so i think that there's there's
something kind of
interesting and ambiguous going on there
now does this unmasking of hypocrisy
work the way
the universal wants it to no it does not
at all
that sort of resolution or
reconciliation
is offered but not achieved so he goes
on
and he says this return of the disparity
present in hypocrisy in a correspondence
is not already an accomplished fact why
because hypocrisy demonstrates its
respect for duty and virtue
just by making a show
of them so hypocrisy puts on
a mask an appearance of duty
and virtue and it does so
for if you're a genuine hypocrite i
suppose you could say there's two kinds
of hypocrites right
there's the hypocrites who are just
about trying to deceive
others right it's it's engaging in
dissimulation to go back to
the previous uh section before
all of this this stuff here
dissimulation right
and it's it's done to deceive others
it's done to
pretend to be virtuous to be fulfilling
duty to be fitting
in to be one of the community
but it's also often done to fool oneself
and in in some respects you know
successful hypocrites
part of what damages them as hypocrites
is the fact that they do deceive
themselves and there's this disjunction
within them between you might say the
essence that's being
expressed in in the sense of the mask
that's putting
being put on and their genuine existence
which is to be
you know doing their own thing whatever
that happens to be whether
i mean doing your own thing could be
like breaking the rules
so as to preserve a person's life or
show compassion
or to you know create artistic
masterpieces it could also be to make
yourself rich
or to impose suffering on others we're
we're not there are
going to be some actually you know bad
actors in in this he's not specifying
what it what it is here
so he goes on and he says it
demonstrates its respect for duty and
virtue just by making a show of them
using them as a mask
to hide itself from its own
consciousness no less than from others
as if
in this acknowledgement on our canon
of the antithesis within itself
identity and correspondence were implied
then hegel uses this language that we've
remarked on in the last several
paragraphs this language of reflection
reflection now being clarified before it
was reflection out of the universal
into itself right and we still have the
into itself part here
but now what is the reflection the
reflection
is out of the spoken
acknowledgement that's how miller is
translating it
anakin der sprache so
out of the acknowledgement the
recognition
again very important term right we're
seeking
recognition as self-consciousness from
other self-consciousnesses
we got it before in this notion of
of duty shared across
a community through the medium of
language so honor kennen
der schrache the recognition
well if we want to play around with this
a little bit yes it could be spoken
acknowledgement the
the recognition or acknowledgement of
language meaning carried out by the
medium of
language it could also mean the
recognition
granted by the language
granted by there being something bigger
than all of us that were caught up
within
a language that is already you could say
moralized and this is so i'm going to go
on a little bit of a digression here
people often especially if they're
coming at language
from a you might say post human
sort of point of view if you know
there's a radical disjunction between
is an ought you know and you can never
get in
an ought from an is they don't realize
that the the you know technically
correct analytic position that they're
taking
doesn't map on to the reality of
language
as it's been used by human beings
basically as far as we can tell from
from its
you know earliest historical
attestations the literature that we have
language is always carrying
but only imperfectly so moral
norms language provides a space in which
morality can be imposed developed
further
applied contested
brought into contradiction with itself
imperfectly expressed that
is part of the nature of communication
so you know i think there's something a
bit bigger
going on here than just language being
the
medium in this case of recognition right
so he says it is at the same time just
as much reflected out of this spoken
acknowledgement and into itself and the
fact that it uses
what is in essence okay so what is the
essence here i mentioned
um the word isn't actually vase and it's
it's on zeke
but we could translate that as the the
essence right
the essence that's supposed to be in
this formal production of identity which
is not actually taking
and it uses that essence the essence of
uh morality the essence of
the moral norms coming from uh
you know the the universal it's using
that
as as a a tool it uses it as a being for
another right in order to get
some sort of acknowledgement or at least
you know response from the other
and he says it implies rather its own
contempt for that essence
and the exposure to everyone of its own
lack of any substantial being
what is lacking substantial being not
the acting consciousness not the evil
but rather the universal the essence
and he says what lets itself be used an
external instrument
shows itself to be a thing ding
right which possesses no importance
uh sphere of its own what lets itself be
used as an external
instrument zoik you know something that
that can just be moved around
so the fact that anybody can talk about
duty the fact that anybody could be a
hypocrite
means in a certain way that anybody
could be a hypocrite
and all this clever talk or
imposing talk of duty and virtue
may not be what it is actually pretended
to be there's no
real substance there at this point
also this identity is not brought about
either by the one-sided persistence of
the evil consciousness
in its own attitude or by the judgment
of the universal consciousness
if the former denies itself in the face
of the consciousness of duty
and declares that what this asserts to
be wickedness to be absolutely
non-identical with the universal
is an action in accordance with inner
law and conscience
then in this one-sided assurance of an
identity there still remains its
non-identity with the other
since this other does not believe it or
acknowledge it
in other words since the one-sided
persistence in one extreme cancels
itself out
evil would it is true thereby confessed
to being evil
but in so doing it would directly
abolish itself and cease to be
hypocrisy and would not as such unmask
itself
it admits in fact a being evil by
asserting that it acts
in opposition to the acknowledged
universal according to its own
inner law and conscience
for if this law and conscience were not
the law of
its single individuality and caprice it
would not be something inner
or particular to it but what is
universally acknowledged
therefore whenever anyone says that he
is acting according to his own law and
conscience against others
he is saying in fact that he is wronging
them
but actual conscience is not this
persistence in a knowing and willing
that opposes itself to the universal
on the contrary the in universal is the
element of its existence
and its language declares its action to
be an acknowledged duty
in paragraph 662 hegel is continuing to
examine the stance of the
labeled as evil consciousness the one
who is appealing to individual
conscience
against the universal and is being
labeled as such
by the rest of the community speaking on
behalf
of the universal and there's this
attempt to
impose a identity you know a
let's try one more time
in paragraph 662 hegel continues
examining this problematic of the
attempt to impose a kind of
identity an identity of existence and
essence and identity
between the evil consciousness
the one that's following its own
conscience
against the universal uh with
it's it's fragmented or discord itself
and
also with the perspective of the
universal this is rather a
you know tall order you might say
and he says listen this just not going
to happen at this point he says
this identity is not brought about and
he says it's not brought about by
either of these two things what are they
the judgment of the universal
consciousness the rutile the
decision the passing judgment upon it
that's not going to work and he doesn't
really
talk that much about that except insofar
as we're talking about the non-identity
what it is that
that conscience makes of the the
universal the stance of the universal
so that's not going to be particularly
helpful there's there's no
agency coming there although we'll see
that emerge in the next paragraph
or the one sided persistence
of the evil consciousness in its own
attitude now the in its own attitude is
a little bit
being read in there on the part of
miller uh
in in the way that it's doing things
right but one-sided whenever we see
hegel using this term
anxiety get one-sided we know that
there's a problem we know that
something is being left out that is
going to have to be
supplied so you know
we're going to arrive ultimately at the
end of this this paragraph
in a sort of impasse or if you like the
fancy greek term for it that people use
these days
opporia right uh and then we'll have to
move beyond that
we're not going to have a resolution
here although interestingly
we do have an auf heimong right we do
have
uh what people like to translate is
sublation
in this case though the uh of haebong is
actually
going to be more destructive than than
productive
so he says that why why aren't we going
to have this identity being brought
about so we have to look at why we
actually have a non-identity going on
here
it says if the former that is the evil
consciousness
denies itself in face of the
consciousness of duty and declares
that what this asserts to be wickedness
to be absolutely non-identical with the
universal
is an action in accordance with inner
law and conscience
then and we'll go on from there but
let's let's
run over that first so if the
if the evil consciousness
both takes in but rejects the point of
view
of the universal the universal does have
a point of view what is that point of
view consistent
it's calling what the evil consciousness
is doing
wickedness or we could say to bring up a
term that was was used earlier
in the culture section basedness
being you know being wrong being bad and
this is a
particular form of of evil right
uh but it's it's like why are you why
are you doing this why can't you fit in
why can't you be a good boy or a good
girl and
make yourself part of this this
community um
it it rejects the evil conscious as
non-you know as being non-identical
with the universal not fitting in being
against duty
and virtue to use the terms that we were
looking at last
paragraph what it is that hypocrisy
is pretending to and here's something
even more important it does not believe
or acknowledge it doesn't provide
recognition
to doesn't provide any ratification to
the evil consciousness it views it as
sort of you know
a cog in the machine that's been
replaced by
you know something that it shouldn't be
a rock
or some jelly or whatever you want it
doesn't
it doesn't really understand it and it
doesn't want to understand it
it wants the individual rather to as we
say get with the program
so he goes on and he says
what this asserts to be wickedness be
non-identical with the universal
is an action in accordance with now this
is how
the evil consciousness is appealing to
itself in justifying itself
to an inner law and conscience
so this is important
conscience we've been talking about this
the entire time right it is is a
certainty of itself but now
he's invoking an inner law
an inner norm right there's a norm
that's opposed to the other
norm we've seen this play itself out
before in
earlier dialectics have we not so in
this case it's the individual
who is acting in accordance
with a law which they provide to
themselves
from where well we're going to get to
that in a moment
so he says uh
here we go in this one-sided assurance
notice that one-sided again of an
identity there still remains its
non-identity with the other what is the
other the universal
it's also the concrete other the other
who is motivated by duty and saying
man you're a hypocrite you're just
trying to do your own thing and you're
putting on
an appearance a face a justification
that doesn't really match who you are
you're doing
something that you want to do but it
doesn't map on to what we all
acknowledge is what we ought to do
you're a fraud
right so that's that's another concrete
consciousness another self-consciousness
in relation to this one
and it's got the universal on its side
so like he says
this other does not believe or
acknowledge it in other words
since the one-sided persistence in one
extreme
cancels itself out and there's the auf
heimong right
he says evil would directly or thereby
confess to being evil now this word
confess
right um
it's a little bit broader than like a
directly juridical confessional
sort of thing or the thing where we oh i
i've been hiding this secret from you i
have to confess
blah blah blah blah blah it can also
mean to like
you know vouch for or or to
acknowledge but in a different sense
than on air cannon right
honor kennen is about you know knowing
the other in a certain way
recognizing uh this is
saying yeah yeah okay i'm i'm evil
i'm bad i'm you know base according to
what you
say according to society's standards
right
we want to get a little facetious with
that and if
we wanted to invoke the uh the dude
right
but that's just your opinion man right
i've got my own opinion inside of me
and that's what really matters to me so
this
abolishing itself
um this this uh
you know this development is
is not something that's totally wiping
itself out
but it does abolish itself
and cease to be hypocrisy and
because it's not hypocrisy at that point
because it's being open it can't unmask
itself
you could say well it just didn't mask
itself no it unmasked itself as
evil it didn't unmask itself as
hypocrisy there's sort of a double
development here right
so the universal wants the individual to
say you're a hypocrite man
admit not just that you're hiding
something but also
that you're a hypocrite it can't happen
right because now it's it's unmasked
itself and said i'm running my own show
i'm going along
with my own law how does it admit to
being evil it doesn't say
oh man you're totally right whatever you
said about me
let me sign the document and confess
it's admitting to be evil
by the very virtue that it's acting in
accordance
with its inner law and conscience why is
this
a problem he says that if this law and
conscience were not the law
of its single individuality and caprice
we'll come back to that
it would not be something inner or
peculiar to it but what is universally
acknowledged if it
now we should pause there for a second
there's there's two ways in which it
could be something universally
acknowledged
it could be that it actually does take
on the point of view of the universal in
which case what it's doing would be just
contradictory
maybe it misapplies the law or something
like that
or it could be invoking a alternate
universal and saying
i you know i'm following this and all
sorts of other people agree with me
many people think right in which case it
would it would betray itself it would no
longer be
staking its own claim according to its
own
inner law right it would be it would not
be
coming from its individuality it would
be just as conformist i mean think about
all these people
you know we joke about hipsters uh and
and they're
wanting to drink pabst blue ribbon which
by the way is a crappy beer you know
there's good reasons why it basically
went out of business before the hipsters
rediscovered it
and then started drinking it and making
a thing out of it nobody
people didn't want to drink it here
where it came from because it wasn't
particularly good right
and it became an emblem for them a way
of like showing how
non-conformist they were this is
admittedly a really trivial example but
i think consumerism provides us with all
sorts of
great uh instances of this so they're
going against the universal and what
would
the universal be only drink stuff that's
actually worth drinking
and instead they all are non-conformists
but they're all non-conformist together
just like the hippies right
back in the 60s oh man we're all doing
our own thing we're all wearing the same
tie dye stuff and you know do having the
same patchouli
oil and you know having the same kind of
signs
i i'm being a bit facetious here
because of course there was a lot of
non-conformism um
and there was a lot of spontaneity but
there also was a lot of
sort of like what we would call here not
buying into the this universal but
buying into a different universal and
claiming that you're doing your own
thing that way
following your own inner law when you're
not really
following your own inner law you're
following somebody else's
inner law so i mean that's not here in
the text but it's definitely something
we could
read in so if this law and conscience
were not the law of its single
individuality
and caprice it would not be something
inner or peculiar to it
now individuality eins own heights
something we've been exploring a lot
through this this section
right caprice
velcro right now that
is a term which can also mean
arbitrariness uh
you know having one's own willfulness
going on there and so you know there's a
bit of a worry here
where is this really coming from is it
just whim
another way we could translate it so he
says therefore when anyone says he's
acting in accordance to his own law and
conscious against
others against what the universal
is saying we ought to do he is saying
in fact that he's wronging them he's
doing wrong to them that's why this is
viewed as
evil but here's where it gets to the
impasse
actual vil will kirlik
conscience gavison is not this
persistence in a knowing and willing
that opposes itself to the universal
it's not just
doing it to oppose itself to the
universal it happens to
oppose itself to this universal on the
contrary
the universal is the element of its
existence and its language declares its
action to be
an acknowledged duty so
it's got to find some way and this is
where we're at an impasse right actual
consciousness
um gavison right
uh has to find some way to reincorporate
the universal into itself
so it's not just individuality and
arbitrariness or caprice
it's got to find some way to
make of itself something that can
recuperate
the universal we might say that's not
happening here at this point
hegel is just asserting that but it's
not being developed as that now we're
going to move on to
yet another side of this this problem
you